in der 14
[Musik]
phoenix runde
schönen guten abend herzlich willkommen
aus berlin ganz herzlich willkommen sage
ich zu wolfgang thierse von der spd er
war erst präsident dann später
vizepräsident des bundestages von 1990
bis 2013 gehörte er dem parlament an
schönen guten abend rtl
und ich begrüße albrecht von lucke
politikwissenschaftler und publizist
redakteur der blätter für deutsche und
internationale politik laut und herzlich
willkommen reinhard schlinkert er ist
gründer und generalbevollmächtigter von
infratest dimap schönen guten abend
gute nirgend und herzlich willkommen
kristina dunz stellvertretende leiterin
des hauptstadtbüros des redaktions
netzwerks deutschland und gerade zurück
aus washington sie haben den
bundeskanzler begleitet und wir freuen
uns dass sie sozusagen direkt aus dem
flieger mehr oder weniger hierher
gekommen sind freut uns der kanzler hat
schlechte umfragewerte viel sagen das
ist der stille kanzler der müsste mehr
führen antwortet ja nicht so gerne auf
fragen da haben die journalisten ihre
erfahrung mit gemacht jetzt haben sie
ihn erlebt auf dieser reise und er
erlebt man den kanzler ja auch im
hintergrund im flugzeug war da anders
aus diesen hintergründen darf man jetzt
nicht eins zu eins berichten man kann
eindrücke
wiedergeben und da hat er sich nicht
anders verhalten als früher in
hintergründen da ist er etwas lockerer
wir haben einen eindruck davon bekommen
für alle sichtbar über dieses foto was
in den sozialen netzwerken und heute
auch in den zeitungen zu sehen war wo er
in so einem lockeren pulli steht und das
mikro lässt sich in der hand hat und ein
lächeln auf den lippen das war meiner
ansicht nach sehr gezielt gesetzt man
durfte am anfang aus diesem
regierungsflieger
fotografieren kleine informationen im
unterschied zu angela merkel seiner
vorgängerin wäre das
möglich da war es nicht erlaubt genau
und insofern sollte diese botschaft ganz
gezielt gesetzt werden dass es zwei
gesichter dieses kanzlers gibt einmal
der staatsmann und einmal der lockere
spd politiker dass er da versucht so
dieses bild aufzubauen um sein image
wieder etwas zu verbessern das ist
glaube ich ziemlich klar ob das verfängt
wir haben gesehen dass es darüber sehr
viel spott gab dass er in einer so
großen weltweiten oder also krise wie
der ukraine krise wo es doch eine
kriegsgefahr in europa gibt dann so
lächelnd und locker im flugzeug sich zu
zeigen kam jetzt nicht so gut an ok also
sie kennen es natürlich schon lange es
ist er ja der kühle zurückhaltende typ
ist das sozusagen ja jetzt wie er
auftritt wie viele sagen ja der der
führt eigentlich zu wenig wie erklären
sie das ist das so dieses arte
hanseatische zurückhaltung oder
verschwiegenheit um der sache willen wie
erklären sie es
wusste dies eine kleine vorbemerkung
machen ich bin ja kein aktiver politiker
mehr und ich bin mir mich in
erinnerung an manche ältere über die ich
mich früher geärgert habe kein seniler
klugscheißer zu sein
und deswegen
halte ich von flotten kommentare
meinerseits nicht so viel ich habe
gelesen dass sein hamburger motto und
das jetzige wohl auch heißt wir sind nie
beleidigt wir sind die historisch
hysterisch nicht laut aber bestimmt sein
das ist wohl sozusagen sein persönlicher
stil der jetzt auf bewährungsprobe
gestellt wird in einer mehrfach
zugespitzten krisenhaften dramatischen
situation einerseits die ukraine krise
andererseits die korona krise das sind
doppelte herausforderung wo sich
erweisen muss dass er das kann woran ich
übrigens glaube dass er führen kann dass
er ernsthafte politik machen kann mit
souveränität mit ruhiger hand
ist jetzt in der bewährungsprobe
unübersehbar und würden sie sagen er
zeigt sich da genug also gerade auch ein
angehender ukraine krise
ich halte nichts davon dass man von
regierungspolitikern erwartet dass sie
unablässig sich öffentlich äußern dass
sie am allgemeinen medialen teilnehmen
sondern ich wünsche mir dass möglichst
hinter verschlossenen türen viele
verhandelt wird viel gesprochen wird
bündnisse geschlossen werden kompromisse
gesucht werden das erwarte ich und
irgendwann mal dass man dann an die
öffentlichkeit tritt das und das ist
unsere position dass am gaang
gemeinsamkeit vereinbart das wollen wir
erreichen das ist vielleicht möglich das
ist nicht möglich ok heßling wir sehen
dass das die umfragewerte nicht so gut
sind für den kanzlern also wie erklären
sie es oder wie stellte sich da
ja es gibt eine ganze reihe von gründen
erstens muss man immer daran erinnern
dass der bundeskanzler mit der spd bei
der letzten bundestagswahl 26 prozent
der abgegebenen stimmen erhalten hat das
war früher schon mal ein bisschen mehr
und wir gucken natürlich auch im
interesse darauf wie es denn mit den
eigenen parteianhängern sid und wenn
sich die regierungskoalition anguckt in
der bewertung zwischen januar und jetzt
februar sind bei den spd-anhängern zwölf
prozent weniger den gut finden die die
arbeit gut finden bei der fdp sind es
zehn und bei den grünen sind satte 17
prozent
die ukraine in unserer letzten
untersuchung haben wir auch festgestellt
dass fast die hälfte der bevölkerung
sagt ja man soll an russland denken und
die nach so soll auch an
sicherheitsgarantien für russland denken
und 70 prozent der deutschen haben
gesagt wir wollen keine
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine also
ist es für den kanzler auch kein ganz
leichtes unterfangen sich dazu behaupten
beruft er sich ja auch wir gucken einmal
noch etwas genauer auf diese grafik von
ihnen von infratest dimap wo man noch
mal sieht wie die bewertung der
politiker aus sieht also wie zufrieden
die bevölkerung mit der arbeit ist von
verschiedenen politikern mit herrn
steinmeier sehr hohe zufrieden sind herr
lauterbach auf -7 und dann sehen wir bei
olaf scholz - 17 das ist natürlich ein
sehr starker absturz herr schlink da
vielleicht noch mal wenn wir das jetzt
so gesehen ist das ein normaler absturz
für einen kanzler nach arbeitsbeginn
also ich habe mir das noch mal angeguckt
wie das bei seinen beiden vorgängern war
wieder das mit schröder und merkel war
und wie die zufriedenheit mit der
bundesregierung sich da entwickelt hat
das war ziemlich ähnlich also die
ströder ziemlich zufrieden die menschen
haben in den ersten drei monaten mit der
regierungsarbeit weniger großes cap bei
merkel auch nicht so starke
unzufriedenheit mit der regierungsarbeit
aber mit ihr persönlich größere
zufriedenheit bei shorts zu beginn der
kanzlerschaft
zufriedenheit mit ihm zufriedenheit mit
der regierungsarbeit das hat sich aber
inzwischen total gedreht und es gibt
also ganz interessant was ich ganz
interessant finde wenn man sich nochmal
die bundestagswahl ergebnisse vor augen
führt damals hatte die cdu bei den
älteren wählern eben nicht zu viel
erfolg wie die spd sie hatte bei den
älteren wähler über 60 über 65 hatte die
spd bei der bundestagswahl 65 35 prozent
jetzt in der letzten umfrage sind noch
und man muss auch noch mal sagen bei den
unteren einkommensschichten also
diejenigen die bis 1500 euro im monat
frei verfügbares haushaltseinkommen
haben liegt die spd bei 15 ganzen 15 und
die l die cdu bei 24 da kommt natürlich
auch die angst vor kommen die
preissteigerung benzin gas heizung kommt
alles zur gleichen zeit und immerhin
gibt es ein drittel der bevölkerung wie
gesagt auch die
maßnahmen zur bekämpfung der pandemie
gehen zu weit okay da kommen gleich noch
mal drauf haben wir etwas
grundsätzlicher am anfang hallo herr von
lucke der in die spd hat ja auch
gewonnen weil eben die viele leute
sagten wir wollen eben diesen stolz als
kanzler und wir wollen nicht herr
laschet also das war ganz klar auch eine
wahl die auf die person gerichtet war
jetzt dieser große absturz also löst er
nicht ein was er versprochen hat er hat
ja immer eigentlich gesagt dass er ein
mensch der ruhigen hand ist nein aber
vielleicht ist die betonung wie sie
angestellt haben auf den letzten beiden
personen die entscheidende schulz ist
nicht primär gewählt wurden wegen
eigener stärke sonne ist zuallererst
geschickt worden weil die schwäche der
anderen eklatant war es war ganz klar
dass es eine nichtwahl von armin laschet
und von annalena baerbock war und diese
tatsache hat olaf scholz im wahlkampf
dazu veranlasst eine strategie zu fahren
keine fehler machen kernbotschaften
minimaler art bloß auch nicht zu sehr in
erscheinung treten er ist abgesehen von
glänzenden plakaten er war als man
präsent werden die anderen ihre leute
dann versuchten zurückzuziehen aber er
konnte sich voll darauf ausruhen dass
die fehler von den anderen gemacht
werden es hat meine meinung nach völlig
verkannt dass er neben tatsächlich nicht
primär aus eigener stärke sondern der
schwäche der anderen wegen gewählt wurde
und diese strategie und ich sehe die
zahlen von den schwingklub jahr zum
ersten mal die zahlen sind die an einem
punkt ganz ganz bemerkenswert
gut zu mir da hab ich auch lindner und
lauterbach stürzen alle um ungefähr
einstelliges ergebnis mal 79 es bleibt
sogar gleich erstaunlich genug weil alle
vier ziemlich viel gemacht haben
ziemlich viel gemacht haben und dafür
offensichtlich nur im einstelligen
bereich abgestraft wenn es gab ja
eklatante fehler scholz und das ist ein
ganz großer fehleinschätzung hat eben
nichts in der ganzen zeit nennenswert in
erscheinung treten getan er hat weiter
die strategie praktiziert ich halte mich
zurück ja ihr habt beispielsweise
konkret machen er hat annalena baerbock
im bundestag zu die politik sprechen
lassen er hat herrn lauterbach ins feuer
der korona debatte geschickt er hat
keine regierungs kompetenz überhaupt
noch reklamiert auf den entscheidenden
fehler das heißt das was natürlich ein
land erwartet dass der mann scholz hat
das an spd das war sie haben zu anfang
gesagt ist der slogan ist wer bei mir
führung bestellt der bekommt sie auch
wenn dieser mann und das ist der zweite
grund probleme gegen die bevölkerung
davor eben gerade nicht so kannte nach
einer 16 jährigen starken kanzlerschaft
von merkel jedenfalls einer die sie
übrigens immer noch zu den
prominentesten figur macht wenn dann der
kanzler in einer krisenhaften kite die
wir in dieser massierung meines
erachtens in der republik geschichte
nicht erlebt haben wenn er dann nicht in
erscheinung tritt dann muss der absturz
oder sie haben sie dass er an macht
nichts herr thierse sie sagen ja er
macht eine menge aber er
trägt das nicht sofort nach außen ist
würden sie einfach locker widersprechen
und ihr seht also ist es richtig dass er
da nicht so dass er zum beispiel im
bundestag nicht rede zur impfpflicht
nicht rede zur ukraine debatte
also zunächst einmal seit diese
regierung im amt ist nehmen wir das
beispiel corona
sind eine menge 30 55 millionen dosen
impfstoff gekauft worden ist ein
expertengremium eingerichtet worden gibt
es einen krisenstab mit der
bundeswehr-general
gibt es herzlichen kontakt
beschränkungen die
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen die
gelegentlich endlos waren sind
offensichtlich jetzt kürzer werden
strafe geführt was den
ministerpräsidenten hinterher machen
aller söder ist etwas anderes das konnte
schon frau merkel liegt sonderlich
beeinflussen also
ein gewisser erfolg natürlich nicht ein
totaler verlangsamung der mikrowelle
damit zeit für boostern damit in
deutschland sozusagen das glimpflicher
ausgegangen vergleichbar nur zudem zu
einer behauptung der kanzler und die
regierung macht nichts also nur auf
diesem beispiel bezogen auf das
außenpolitische thema die ukraine krise
wiederhole ich mich da geht es nicht so
sehr darum dass ein kanzler oder
irgendein regierungs mit pathetisch
erklärt sondern was man durch
verhandlungen zu erreichen versucht aber
braucht er hinderten das findet sich auf
dem öffentlichen markt statt
ich halte nichts davon dass man
außenpolitik gerade in besonders
schwierigen situation meint durch
öffentliches geschrei zu erreichen da
bin ich sehr skeptisch also dieser
kanzler und diese regierung sind es 60
tage im amt
manches erinnert mich an 1998 anfang 99
der jugoslawische bürgerkrieg rot grün
war im amt und wir wurden über von
überfallen durch eine dramatische krise
es ist jetzt etwas ähnliches das dauert
ein paar tage ein paar wochen
und man sieht wo man sich sozusagen
zurechtfinden muss und wenn ich richtig
sehe ist der kanzler jetzt unterwegs in
washington in kiew in moskau wir werden
sehen was er dabei zustand ist aber die
frage ob er sich wirklich da ändert
droht uns und dann hat es ist ja
zumindest erstmal festzustellen dass der
schaden schon da ist also ob
nato-partner ganz stark die usa beklagen
eine unsichtbarkeit des kanzlers
deswegen ja auch die frage wo ist
eigentlich olaf scholz ist in den usa so
dass deutschland als schlechtes
schwächstes glied unter den nato
partnern bezeichnet wurde was daran
liegt dass sie nicht feststellen konnten
wofür steht dieser bundeskanzler und man
muss sich genau an seine strategie
wahlkampf erinnern da hat er immer
eigentlich gesagt er wird der natürliche
nachfolger von angela merkel also nicht
nur mehr fortschritt wagen wie der
koalitionsvertrag überschrieben ist
sondern auch kontinuität
versprechen und diese kontinuität ist
nicht eingetreten und es ist richtig
wenn hier so sagt es ist ein neuer
bundeskanzler 60 tage ist er ist um amt
aber er war viele jahre vize kanzler und
er hat vier jahre auch miterlebt wie
sich diese ukraine krise noch weiter
entwickelt hat also er ist ja überhaupt
kein neuling er weiß in den themen
beschied er weiß wie man regiert und das
alles hat er in den 60 tagen nicht
gemacht hat eine lücke gerissen die
deutschland auf internationaler bühne
zumindest ganz stark beim wichtigsten
verbündeten der usa als unzuverlässig
hat erscheinen lassen und das muss er
jetzt erst mal wieder aufholen und wenn
man ich gebe und er das also hatten sie
den eindruck dass das das also beiden
hat ja sehr stark darauf sei die sehr
stark betont wie gutes verhältnis ist
und die vertrauensvoll das behält also
dass der us-präsident sagt nein er hat
keine zweifel an der zuverlässigkeit
deutschland ist für mich so der ausdruck
dessen das muss eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein dass die usa
keine zweifel an der zuverlässigkeit
deutschland hat ein wenn er das so
betonen muss dann sehen sie daran dass
er das aufräumen musste und wenn sie
erst auf dem level anfangen dann wird
das natürlich schwieriger schnell in
diese krisenbewältigung zu kommen und
insofern hat der us-präsident jetzt
einmal ein positives signal für den
deutschen kanzler gesetzt aber natürlich
könnte man weiter sein und es ist eine
selbstverständlichkeit erklärt worden
und dafür musste erst dieser besuch
passieren und das ist in so einer krise
nicht der anspruch an deutsche
führungsfähigkeit wie sie in den letzten
jahren eigentlich klar war dass link hat
sie wollten glaube ich laden gerade da
noch was zu sagen wenn ich richtig
verstanden habe erstens wurde zweimal zu
allen lucke der natürlich völlig recht
hat
vor dem vorfall mit dem
kanzlerkandidaten cdu armin laschet der
dann im falschen moment lachte lagen die
cdu nach vorne und auch die
zufriedenheit mit ihm und olaf scholz
waren ziemlich gleich dann haben wir das
ergebnis erlebt dass die besonders die
älteren wähler gesagt haben nein
das tolerieren wir nicht so was den
wellen wenig das hatten wir schon mal
vor vielen vielen jahren in hessen als
roland koch sagte
kinder unter 14 müssen im zweifelsfall
ins gefängnis gab es auch einen großen
abstürzte ist der eine punkt der andere
punkt ist wenn wir die menschen fragen
hier in deutschland was für probleme
haben sie denn steht an erster stelle
corona an zweiter stelle
energiekosten weil das merken die leute
jeden tag und ukraine ist ziemlich weit
weg und dann gibt es noch einen
interessanten unterschied jetzt sparen
war ja auch mal der liebling der nation
spätestens als angekündigt wurde wir
haben jetzt in impfmittel und machen
lauter impfzentren du leider gab es da
nicht genug impfstoff und er stürzte
radikal ab deshalb war merkel überhaupt
nie beschädigt merkel ist immer in der
zustimmung ganz oben geblieben weil es
auch verstanden hat
solche situationen zu managen und die
frage ist wie lange lauterbach jetzt als
hoffnungsträger aller der leute die
sagen wir haben die nase voll von der
pandemie wir müssen endlich was machen
und wenn sie jetzt hören ist war
vielleicht noch eine vierte impfung ist
das ein thema was die leute viel viel
mehr interessiert als die diskussion
über die ukraine und die frage liefern
oder waffen liegt aber keine waffen die
wollen natürlich dass erstmal ihre
probleme vor ort gelöst werden und sie
nicht zwei euro oder ein euro 80 für
ihren sprit bezahlen müssen wird haben
sie auch bei der gleichen frage was ist
mit der mit der nord stream ist auch die
meinung 50 50 volt machen oder nicht
aber im osten ist die zustimmung
natürlich sehr hoch auch weil da braucht
man ja auch arbeitskräfte und ist auch
ein bisschen den russischen ehemaligen
besatzungen geneigte als die menschen im
westen da war es ja total interessant in
washington hervor dass olaf scholz nicht
einmal das wort in austria in den mund
nahmen hat ist ja also beiden hat es ja
dann genannt aber weder gazprom noch
pipeline er hat einfach er erwähnt es
einfach nicht kann er sich das
eigentlich erlauben es ist ja ein noch
viel größeres politikum das sich joe
biden ich sage mal erlaubt hat zu sagen
wir werden dafür sorgen sinngemäß das
nord stream da nicht kommt das alleine
ich habe es noch gar nicht in dem maße
diskutiert erlebt ist ja ein politikum
sondergleichen der us-amerikanische
präsident sagt ich stehe dafür dass dann
nämlich kommt der kanzler sagt dazu
nichts dabei ist es natürlich im kern
der sache einen zwischen deutschland und
russland
praktiziert das unternehmen also damit
will ich sagen auch das war nun nicht
gerade ausdruck großer souveränität ich
nehme an er hat gründe gehabt er hat ja
versucht alles in der palette sollte
versuchte dezidiert ein argument daraus
dass ihn das sagte wir halten unsere
möglichkeiten im unklaren aber wenn der
us präsident
vor seiner sicht sagt ich werde dafür
sorgen dass dem nicht so ist dann ist
das per se auch nicht umhin eine
stärkung des bundeskanzlers wenn er das
dazu nichts sagt und sich zurückhält
also damit will ich sagen auch dieser
besuch hat meines erachtens nur bedingt
zur stärkung beigetragen ich fand den
auftritt trotzdem recht gut ich muss
sagen die pressekonferenz da gab er sich
zumindest entschieden man versuchte auch
insgesamt was aber so kontrastiert auch
zu seinem auftritt wieder im flieger war
er versuchte da sehr ernst natürlich die
amerikanische presse überzeugen wollen
deutlich zu machen ich nehme es ernst
wir sind voll an der seite der
vereinigten staaten das hat meiden ja
auch bewerkstelligt trotzdem es gibt es
stinkt tatsache dass entscheidende doch
ein ganz bemerkenswertes phänomen
die tatsache dass auch gerade olaf
scholz und nicht karl lauterbach so
dezidiert ab stürzt auch gerade in der
mit dem hintergrund der korona krise
zeigt dass die erwartungen an den
kanzler gerichtet sind die hat er im
wahlkampf geweckt und ich glaube hat ein
ganz grundsätzliches problem wir kennen
scholz zwar seit 20 jahren und trotzdem
kennt ihn im lande niemand und glaubt
auch niemand ihn nur annähernd so gut
wie wir angela merkel nach 16 jahren
kanzlerschaft kannten dieses kontinuität
zu versprechen was das schönste was aber
stolze einem satz was scholz versuchte
im wahlkampf aber die raute machte
glaubte er ich bin die verheißung des
konflikts versprochen es fällt dann auch
nicht zurück da hat er sich völlig
getrogen weil er viele leute im land bis
heute nicht mit einem klaren image
seiner person klar gemacht und das er in
der korona krise so ausfällt und sich
auch hinter lauterbach versteckt das ist
doch jedem deutlich weil er auch die
mehrheiten im in seinem kabinett nicht
hat das feld auf ihn zurück und das ist
dramatisch ich bedauere das übrigens
zutiefst dass einer mal gesagt weil
diese ja dass die koalition diese diesen
ballast den sie ganz früh auf dem rücken
hat dass sie ihn bis zum ende wenn sie
läuft sie läuft gefahr nicht loszuwerden
als eine ganz schwache in ihren
konstellationen schwache konstellationen
die frage ist ja wie frei also auch bei
diesem weg wird immer gern bei den
ostring bleiben hängt hier sind noch mal
fragen wie wie frei ist denn olaf scholz
da eigentlich war das ist ja in der spd
tatsächlich ja nicht unumstritten ist es
klar dass das manuela schwesig als
ministerpräsidenten von vorpommern daran
festhalten will dazu kam lars klingbeil
als hat dann die mit russland befassten
ministerien minister zusammengerufen und
hatten versuchten einheitlichen kurs zu
machen da war scholz gar nicht dabei
dann hat man herrn schröder der vom
säbelrasseln der ukraine spricht dann
hat man ja gabriel der aber waffen
liefern bild an die ukraine also wie wie
wie kann scholz da wie sollte er da
agieren wie sollte die spd sich darauf
stellt hier sind also zunächst einmal
will ich noch eine kleine vor bemerkten
machen den look kannten wir frau merkel
wirklich nach 16 jahren hatten diese vor
allem aber dient also also lassen wir
das mal sein ich bin auch nicht sicher
frau dunst dass der schaden schon gar
ist vielleicht bin ich nicht er ist ja
schon da er momentan nachsatz vielleicht
bin ich nicht sensibel genug aber eine
schlechte presse in den usa ist das
schon wirklich schaden ich erinnere mich
an die regierung schröder gehabt hatte
die deutschland auch eine ganz schlechte
presse weil wir bei bestimmten
kritischen aktionen nicht mitgemacht
haben wir gehört eigentlich zur
koalition der willigen die spaltung des
westlichen bündnisses oder dramatisch in
den usa und den deutschen zeitungen und
medien geschrieben also an dieser stelle
bin ich etwas gelassener nun zum
austrian nehmen wir doch gerhard
schröder nicht mehr so wichtig ist es ja
nicht mehr war kanzler dass es lange her
jeder weiß auch jeder sozialdemokrat war
ist in dem moment wo putin die
ukrainische grenze übertritt ist nostrum
erledigt das weiß jeder darüber braucht
man gar nicht reden und deswegen sage
ich ich habe auch etwas dagegen dass man
in außenpolitik missversteht
dass man immer verlangt dass kessler
hüte gegrüßt werden der gessler gut 1
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine war
gestern gut zwei man muss immer fort
abschwören von nord stream also ich
glaube wirklich außenpolitik ist glaube
ich etwas differenzierter und mühseliger
als diese art von öffentlichen verlangen
nach kessler gegen trotzdem
bevölkerung doch gerne wissen wo es
langgeht wenn er kann sagt er sagt es
geht um nichts weniger als krieg in
europa zu verhindern dann ist das ja wie
sehr
hat doch stolz das ist doch gar nicht
misszuverstehen wenn er sagt alles alles
steht auf dem prüfstand das heißt auch
noch stream ist dabei aber dann könnt
ihr jetzt auch sagen dann könnte er auch
sagen auch dazu gehört auch nachweisbar
sind aber machen präventiv sanktionen
machen sie sinn das geht es im endlauf
sanktionen hätten
es geht noch nicht ich will nur sagen es
geht doch darum dass vielleicht noch
so wie etwa makro
der auch keine öffentlichen bekenntnisse
dieser art abgibt wie man sie jetzt von
scholz verlangt hingeht und mü serie
gespräche führt das kann den erinnerer
gleichen
das kann man doch nicht vergleichen
diese gas pipeline führt von russland
nach deutschland insofern hat es
gewicht wenn der kanzler was sagt und
wenn ich noch mal darauf zurückkommen da
wo der schaden bereits da ist der starke
mann in europa ist im moment emanuel
makro der mehrfach mit putin telefoniert
hat der gestern abend da war und der
jetzt wahrgenommen wird als derjenige
sehr was regen han und herr scholz muss
das jetzt wieder einfangen heute abend
ist er mag in berlin man will sich noch
mal abstimmen mit der strategie war ja
der bundeskanzler nächste woche nach
moskau fährt aber er musste das erst mal
wieder zurückholen und da würde ich
gerne daran erinnern wie es 2015 war als
schon einmal eine initiative zur lösung
des ukraine konflikts nach der annexion
russland der krim also der russischen
aktion der krim passiert ist wo sich die
bundeskanzlerin mit an die spitze der
bewegung gesetzt hat zusammen mit
frankreich und jetzt geht es erstmal
darum dass man das wieder zusammenführen
muss das wird jetzt geschehen dass das
das kriegen die jetzt wieder zusammen
und trotzdem ist ja eine irritation da
und wenn ich noch ganz kurz etwas zu den
waffenlieferungen sagen darf es geht ja
schon gar nicht mehr um
waffenlieferungen von deutschland an die
ukraine das gilt so gut wie
ausgeschlossen
dh deutschland hat ohnehin den part der
diplomatie und wenn man den hat dann
muss man den voll ausspielen und herr
scholz kann jetzt wieder durch die
entwicklung in dieser woche und durch
seine reisetätigkeit er wird auch nach
kiel fahren da wieder versuchen da
reinzukommen aber dass man von ihm eine
haltung erwartet und es ist da hat sich
die zeit verändert die menschen wollen
erklärung sie wollen wissen wo die reise
hingehen und da muss es keine preisliste
geben sanktion 1 für drei soldaten
russland in der ukraine und sanktion 2
für mehrere aber es muss klar sein wohin
die reise geht und deswegen wenn man
sagt es liegt alles auf dem tisch und
man wird fünfmal oder 50 mal gefragt ob
dazu diese ostsee pipeline gehört dann
kann man dazu eine haltung hat es sei
denn was ich nicht weiß er macht ist das
wäre allerdings wirklichen co wenn er
das in moskau macht wenn er in moskau
sagen würde und im übrigen gehört nord
stream zwei dazu dann wäre das eine
wucht die wir jetzt vielleicht noch
nicht absehen können vielleicht ist das
so weil der neubau journalisten im
hintergrund bereit sich der etwas in die
karten gucken zu lassen nein er sagt da
tatsächlich nichts anderes als auch
sonst und was mich so ein bisschen stört
ist dass die der bundeskanzler ein
bisschen den eindruck vermittelt alle
die ihn danach fragen was meinen sie
genau mit harten konsequenzen und was
meinen sie genau damit dass alles auf
dem tisch liegt unterstellt er den
fragestellern immer dass man selber jahr
eine eskalation wolle und krieg wolle
und wenn man danach fragt wen meinen sie
eigentlich genau welche medien welche
politiker dann hält er das im ungefähren
und das ist für mich nun souveräne
haltung also eher könnte das ausräumen
und er lässt es vielleicht auch im
rückgriff auf sein wahlkampf wo er auch
vieles sehr offen gelassen hat und
erfolg damit bekommen hat ich glaube nur
dass die situation eine ganz andere ist
und dass dieser bundeskanzler auch
anfangen muss zu erklären herr schlink
hat sie hatten sich gemeldet
ja ich würde noch mal sagen wir reden ja
in denen die meiste zeit im moment über
die ukraine an nord stream und waffen
oder nicht waffen aber ja vorhin schon
mir erlaubt zu sagen das ist aber nicht
das sind nicht die themen die die
menschen allermeisten bewegen in
deutschland da sind andere und dabei ist
natürlich auch interessant wurde ja
gerade 2015 erwähnt da haben sich
frankreich und deutschland glaube ich
viel viel besser verstanden also im
moment man erinnert sich jetzt nur mal
erfahren dass frankreich sagt wir wollen
aber weiter atomkraftwerke um die co2
emissionen zu reduzieren wir wollen auch
gaskraftwerke und während das in
deutschland ja im moment politisch
völlig undenkbar ist also auch da gibt
es ja diskussionen zwischen den beiden
ländern die es vorher nicht gegeben hat
und das makro in die ukraine fliegt und
erst nach russland und in die ukraine
als der vermittler hin und her das ist
natürlich eine rolle wo sich ein
deutscher bundeskanzler hätte er die
rolle von makro übernommen sicherlich
sehr beliebt hätte machen können auf der
anderen seite sie sagen klar das
außenpolitische auftreten ist sozusagen
nicht entscheidend für seine
zustimmungswerte im innern richtig
verstehe ich sie richtig nein eine klar
natürlich klar aber ich sage es nochmal
sind energiekosten und heizungskosten es
wird über eg gesprochen es sieht alles
sachen wo die leute feststellen dass ihr
portmonee belastet wird dass sie weniger
geld in der tasche haben dass die
anregungen oder die haben ja gesagt dass
alles besser gehen mit uns und die leute
warten jetzt darauf dass es ihnen besser
geht und natürlich wird die ukraine dazu
aber sie ist nicht der entscheidende
spiel faktor es wäre für ihn die
möglichkeit gewesen zur höhere und
popularität auf einem auf dem
außenpolitischen gebiet aber noch war
das problem ist noch mal nach wie vor
omikron und energiepreise genau das ist
ein viel größeres problem und natürlich
viel mehr für die menschen der verlage
haben sie den eindruck dass oder wie
könnte es denn ihrer meinung nach wieder
zu einem punkt kommen wo leute mehr
zustimmung geben denn er hatte ja sehr
hohe zustimmungswerte ja und die hatte
er nicht zuletzt deshalb auch weil er
dieses versprechen gemacht hat ich gebe
die orientierung wir haben doch in
diesem land überhaupt eine ungeheure
orientierung sehnsucht das ist auch kein
zufall wenn man wie olaf scholz
beispielsweise sagt wir stehen vor einer
jahrhundertaufgabe holt er recht hat
sind in einem zugang wo wir eine neue
industrielle revolution brauchen die
völlige umstellung auf transformative
also nicht fossile energien neue
formen dann kann er auch da nicht robert
habeck gewissermaßen als außenposten
alleine fahren lassen ich glaube das
land hat sehr genau begriffen in all den
feldern ja stimmt sagt sie zu recht auch
die energie explosion es ist ein
zusammenfallen von einer orientierungs
bedürftigkeit bei dem wissen um riesige
herausforderungen bei dem niemand anders
gefordert ist als der kanzler und wenn
der kanzler in einer solchen situation
diese führungs bereitschaft die im
übrigens auch grundgesetz zugeschrieben
ist er bestimmt die richtigen der
politik wenn er das vermissen lässt
obwohl er ist gerade versprochen hat
dann fällt das zutrifft auf insgesamt
koalition so dargestellt so von wir sind
ja alle beste freunde und sehr
unterkriegen das gehalt untereinander
hin und haben auch nicht rausgelassen
bei den kollegen
das ist doch kompletter das haben wir
immer als wahnsinnig toll wahrgenommen
das war übrigens auch von schuld sei ich
ausdrücklich am anfang ausgesprochen
clever er hat damit den grünen und der
fdp enorme freude bereitet die konnten
sich um die arme fallen und die grünen
waren beseelt davon dass sie plötzlich
auf der grünen seite sind sie waren
danach enttäuscht gar nicht passen dass
er jetzt eine verführung sein sohn nach
wenig das ist der große wir müssen ja in
einer gewissen abfolge denken in dem
augenblick als er es geschafft hat es
war ja kein ganz einfaches unterfangen
grüne und fdp mussten die bereitschaft
aufbringen ihnen diese spd koalition zu
gehen sie hätten sich mit großem aplomb
18 cdu werben als er es aber geschafft
hatte als erst geschafft hatte kannst da
dann zu sein hätte er meines erachtens
absolut in die offensive gehen müssen
und deutlich machen müssen wo will
dieses land mit mir hin und er macht es
in keinem seiner felder es liegt
übrigens auch ganz eindeutig an dem
umstand das weiß er auch genau dass er
nicht der mensch ist der ein
menschenfänger wäre er ist auch nicht
die figur da machen wir doch nichts
sagen ja nichts falsches der bisher
durch leidenschaftliche rede in
erscheinung er wird es machen müssen ich
glaube das land wird nicht damit
zufrieden sein wenn er alles auslagert
an frau berg an den herrn lindner und
lauterbach genau hin daran wird herr
scholl zu scheitern und wir sehen es
einen umfrage gehen wenn er hat hier
sind würden was würden sie dazu sagen
wie sie müsste wie sollte er schon jetzt
mit dieser ampel koalition weiter
umgehen soll er da der starke kanzler
sein der die ganz klar auf seine
richtlinienkompetenz setzt oder bei ja
sozusagen er das team spielen lassen
missverstehen von lucke mal und
artikulieren die sehnsucht nach einem
basta kannst
naja
ich glaube die verabredung in den in den
koalitionsverhandlungen war wohl die
sich wechselseitig gelten zu lassen
und ich glaube das ist sozusagen auch
der stil dieses anfangs gewesen sonst
stimme ich zu ich glaube auch dass
angesichts der gleichzeitigen krisen die
wir haben der zunehmenden nervosität und
ungeduld in der gesellschaft der kanzler
sozusagen einmal sehr grundsätzlich noch
einmal die agenda seiner regierung und
die grundposition in
entscheidenden fragen erklären
mache einen kleinen unterschied zwischen
haltung und erklärung ich glaube die
haltung wird man ihm nicht absprechen
können die hat etwas auch mit der
tradition der entspannungs politik zu
tun dass man weiß auch in konflikt mit
russland in mit diesem autoritären
system putins gilt der grundsatz es gibt
nur gemeinsam ist ja nicht sicherheits
gegeneinander sondern nur miteinander
das gilt auch hier unter fisch während
mit denen und übersichtlich mit denen
man das muss man die das ist eine
vernünftige haltung aber muss erklären
was man tut man kann im grunde erst
etwas erklären wenn man unterwegs ist
und ich hoffe sehr dass nach den reisen
nach washington kiew und moskau und nach
gesprächen mit makro das ist ja
vernünftig dass man gemeinsam politik
gegenüber russland
verabredet definiert ich weiß nicht was
man da zurückholen muss sondern das
miteinander sie haben vorher miteinander
geredet die beiden jetzt reden sie heute
miteinander und danach wird man kaum
noch mal reden und das wird noch mal
reden ich halte das für ziemlich
vernünftig dass man solche art
verabredete politik macht bis hin an den
grenzen der der demütigung mit putin
verhandelt um einen krieg
das ist das eine thema aber das andere
thema häftling gesagt die korona die
energiepreise alters beschäftigt die
menschen ja sehr und auch da erwarten
sie eine eine führungsrolle und haben
sie den eindruck dass wenn er scholz
jetzt der so stolz darauf ist dass er
ins kanzleramt geschafft hat natürlich
völlig zu recht nach diesen erst
schlechten voraussetzungen
dass er wenn er jetzt sieht das eher so
abstürzt in diesen umfragen dass ihm das
was ausmacht und dass er da sein stil
eventuell ändert oder haben sie das
gefühl dass eigentlich egal nein ich
schätze ihn so ein dass er sich jetzt
darf man erst mal nicht beeindrucken
lässt und das wäre ja auch richtig also
wenn jetzt immer nach umfragen politik
machen würde das würde das würde ihnen
nicht helfen und ich halte ihn für so
selbstbewusst da schüttelt er sich und
und wartet auf die nächste kurve die
wieder nach oben geht ich würde ein
punkt gerne von herrn schlinkert
aufgreifen der sagt außenpolitik ist für
die menschen nicht so entscheidend das
stimmt aber in den ganzen zusammenhang
ob eine milliarden teure gas pipeline in
betrieb geht oder nicht er weckt
natürlich immer so auch die die furcht
haben die eigentlich genügend gas haben
wir sind wir sind wir gut versorgt und
dann reiht sich einst an das andere in
der ukraine krise nicht vorangegangen in
der impfpflicht als
bundestagsabgeordneter gesprochen nicht
als bundeskanzler schere im kopf also
eine meinung gesagt aber nicht voran
gegangen und wenn ich noch mal auf die
atomkraft und noch ganz auseinander dazu
und auch das ziel der impfungen nicht
erreicht
da würde
der regierung immer so johannes lagemann
das ist ja das hat er zugegeben aber da
würde ich sagen da ist ja auch die
gesellschaft zu einem großen teil selber
daran schuld und dann noch ein punkt zur
atomkraft das ist der dritte punkt
frankreich möchte es eben als nachhaltig
einstufen in der eu kommission und der
kanzler sagt im auftreten in paris neben
herrn makro sagt er eigentlich jedes
land muss es so machen wie es meint dass
es richtig ist auch da keine klare kante
da hätte man ja auch sagen können das
kommt für uns eigentlich in frage da
muss man nochmal sprechen also
aneinandergereiht große themen wo in der
bevölkerung jetzt erstmal nicht so klar
ist jeder davor an was villa genau
unterlässt er eben das team die
bundestag und die die koalition machen
und ich glaube da muss er in die da muss
er was man so sagt vor die welle kommen
weil sonst 3 wird er gilt lernidee
sozusagen ja dann auch jetzt eine
position die friedrich merz als neue
oppositionsführer dann füllen kann herr
schlinkert wie sieht denn dann kann der
die cdu kann die union kann friedrich
merz können sie profitieren von der
schwäche scholz hat er die man ihm jetzt
attestiert
viele menschen sagen ja wer märz
kanzlerkandidat gewesen würde der
kanzler jetzt nicht olaf scholz heißen
das wort hier auch die mehrheit der cdu
an mitglieder und dem man sieht welche
zustimmung er bei der wahl zu der als
parteivorsitzender erhalten hat egal ob
er 66 jahre alt ist was ihr auch zitiert
wird da wird man sehen wo der weg
hingeht aber er wird sicherlich klarere
positionen
beschreiten als das olaf scholz im
moment tut und natürlich profitiert die
cdu davon im moment sagen zwar nur ein
drittel gutes drittel an die 40 prozent
sind mit der arbeit von ihm zufrieden
aber da gibt es ja noch nicht so sehr
viel also seinen wahlergebnissen aber es
ist nicht zu erwarten dass die cdu
aufgrund von der wahl von merz jetzt
wieder an zustimmung in den umfragen
verliert im gegenteil da hat die fdp
auch große sorge vor weil sie dem leser
hat okay wenn jetzt märz kommt und wie
wirtschaftspolitik wieder besetzt was
sie denn eigentlich mit uns wie wichtig
bleiben denn einig auf welchem niveau
bleiben wir stehen die freuen sich sehr
die fdp dass sie zweistellig geblieben
ist ja hätte was wir vorher was bedeutet
das denn wenn die umfragen als nicht so
gut sind für die spd die ja jetzt nach
vielen jahren der zerstrittenheit und
der uneinigkeit ja doch sehr einig war
und sehr klar und sehr diszipliniert
agiert befürchten sie da dass die spd
dann ja da wieder dass der alte kämpfer
aufbrechen
also ich hoffe sehr dass meine partei
dann nicht gleich wieder nervös wird
aber ich will noch etwas sagen zu diesem
wunsch nach klarer kante aus
journalisten sicht mag dieser wunsch
verständlich sein aber nehmen wir die
beiden beispiele war dunst an denen sie
das abgehandelt waren in paris atom
frage welchen sinn macht es würden
olaf scholz neben mag eine klare
position hat seit jahrzehnten dieselbe
dann auftrumpfen sagt wir halten das
aber für falsch für katastrophal unser
weg ist der allein selig machende das
wäre klare kante welchen sinn macht
wollte sich ja nicht würde sie gegen der
zweite beispiel impfpflicht das ist bei
dem thema impfpflicht um erkennbar um
keine parteipolitische frage habt das
sich erkennbar dabei auch
unterschiedliche meinungen in der
regierungskoalition gibt vor allem in
der fdp die selbst gibt es
unterschiedliche meinungen
und in der bevölkerung und man sieht ja
dass jetzt die cdu von der fahne und
plötzlich sie hat zugestimmt eine
berufsbezogene in pflicht und jetzt
macht sie das gegenteil also man sieht
wie und die realisierungs problem das
man dann sagt es macht keinen sinn jetzt
hier von oben her wir wissen was mit
regierung her sondern etwas
durchzusetzen sondern jetzt müssen wir
eine frage die erkennbar ganz viele
andere fragen berührt im parlament
debattieren ausführlich in der
bevölkerung wobei er wobei er vorher
gesagt wobei es ja vorher gesagt er will
an im februar/märz gern eine impfpflicht
haben in einer weile doch das ist doch
das problem herr thierse er hat ja genau
den anspruch erhoben und wenn ich mich
in einer solchen weise die eine
ungeheure hypothek für scholz werden
wird sie sagen das völlig zurecht die
cdu muss die platte macht sich von der
fahne hat bereits mit der
pflegekraft bezogenen endlich den anfang
gemacht sie wird bei der allgemeinen
pflicht allen gesetzesvorhaben die man
jetzt bereits kennt auch tun scholz
würzig und dafür ist er nun mal der
kanzler er wird sich an seinem wort weit
mehr messen lassen müssen dass er diese
im pflicht versprochen hat und das ist
ein grund großes problem
hat weit mehr verheißen und die
taxonomie ist auch ein beispiel dafür
wenn es alles was man auch übrigens in
hoffnung für die junge generation wir
schaffen die progressive ökologische
wende wenn das in vielen kleinen
einzelbereichen konterkariert wird dann
sagt der große anspruch und ablauf des
kanzlers mit dem er im wahlkampf
angetreten ist sie ein so viel zusammen
und das ist der einzige grund sonst
würde ich mir diese zweistelligen
absturz von scholz gar nicht erklären
können und da wird er mehr aus der
defensive kommen müssen und ich glaube
sogar vor uns ich würde in einem punkt
widersprechen er wird das ihn mit
argusaugen beobachten wie der stand
seiner werte ist auch wenn er eines
natürlich weiß deswegen auch der
schlabberpulli ich sage es mal salopp
auf der fahrt er sagt ich damit hat er
signalisiert ich habe alles im griff ich
kann sogar ist mir leisten im wege zum
wichtigsten auftritt meiner bisherigen
karriere nämlich in washington bin ich
im schlabberpulli im flugzeug aber er
weiß doch eines ganz genau diese
umfragewerte die er jetzt schon auf die
nächsten drei landtagswahlen saarbrücken
schleswig-holstein also saarland
schleswig holstein und nordrhein
westfalen im mai die er als regelrechten
gegenwind für seine eigenen kandidaten
die auf rückenwind osten transportiert
sind für ihn schon so entscheidend weil
der abstand zwischen spd und cdu ist
einer bei dem drei prozent die nur
wechseln die verschenkter satz
beschrieben die jetzt schon auf seiten
der cdu gelandet sind darüber den
ausschlag geben wer eines tages die nase
vorn haben wird es ist ein so minimaler
wimpernschlag mit dem die spd gewonnen
hat ich bin gespannt ob scholz die ruhe
bewahrt dass er sagt ich bin auf
dreieinhalb jahre noch gewählt das kann
sein aber er muss sich wahnsinnig sorgen
dass unsere demoskopie geleitete
republik nicht permanent im blick hat
deswegen glaube ich ist das eine
simulierte ruhe dann geht da geht sehr
schnell der stift und ich bedaure leider
auch letzte das ich bedauere dass die
ganze koalition in diesen dreieinhalb
jahren wenn es nicht einen echten schub
gibt auch ein echter führungsstärke ihre
riesenprojekte alle nicht schaffen wird
und dann wird der anspruch immer mehr
konterkariert von der harten
wirklichkeit und das befürchte ich ja
dort ist auch ein dreierbündnis sicher
nicht zusammenfinden müssen herr
schlinkert sie hatten sich gemeldet
glaube einsatz wurde er nur da ist
angesprochen wurde schon zu nordrhein
westfalen sagen das ist natürlich auch
verblüffend im dezember die spd ganz
klar vorne vor der cdu und jetzt bei
unserer letzten untersuchungen liegen zu
kopf an kopf da haben sich auch glaube
sind auch sechs prozent plus minus 6%
plus bei der cdu gekommen das sind ja
immerhin keine so großen verwunderlichen
zuwächse wenn man denkt wie schlecht
armin laschet bewertet wurde das sage
ich märz und die cdu wird interessant
aber wenn die drei landtagswahlen
verloren gingen für die spd die cdu
bürger überall an der macht bleiben das
wird dann bestimmt auch ganz interessant
wie das dann innerhalb der spd
diskutiert wird freut uns was erwarten
sie wird es eine änderung geben auch in
der in der art der kommunikation von
scholz ich halte ihn dafür nicht
unbedingt in der lage weil er das seit
vielen jahren so praktiziert er hat sich
darin in dieser rolle auch schon so
gefallen als er hamburger bürgermeister
war mit immer mit einem sehr großem
selbstbewusstsein deswegen glaube ich
nicht dass er das ändern wird und ich
glaube auch nicht dass er auf
umfragewerte schaut weil man sich an 1
erinnern muss er hatte ein jahr lang lag
die spd bei 15 und er hat gesagt ich
werde bundeskanzler ich glaube dass er
und er hat es geschafft das würde ihn
nicht irritieren und drei länder von
denen sie sprachen sind cdu regiert das
heißt also wenn die spd ist nicht
schafft den machtwechsel zu vollziehen
ist sie noch nicht so schlimm dran als
wenn man aus von einem posten des
ministerpräsidenten oder präsidentin
etwas verliert insofern glaube ich ist
er da ist er da gar nicht so unter druck
und das sich in nrw das wieder verändert
zugunsten der cdu liegt ja sehr stark
daran dass der dortige ministerpräsident
derzeit vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist und
alle drei wochen als in diesem an wo
erfolge sind so gedreht wo sich herr
scholz zurück geld und auch da wiederum
andere geht hält über nicht gut vielen
dank frau dunst herr thierse herr
schlink hat und der von luca für diese
diskussion vielen danke ihnen fürs
zuschauen morgen schauen wir auf eines
der probleme die linke hat ja eben noch
mal angesprochen hat nämlich die
pandemie natürlich und fragen lockern
oder abwarten der streit um die korona
maßnahmen wäre schön wenn sie dabei sind
und jetzt gehts weiter für nix da der
tag bis dann tschüss
[Musik]